[موسيقى]
أنا أكاديمي، ربما يكون أصعب
شيء أواجهه في المنزل هو
علامة المعرض، لكن إذا قام الإسرائيليون بغزونا
إذا هاجمونا بالواقع المعزز،
افتح الباب أيضًا لذبحنا، سأستخدم
تلك العلامة  رميها على
الجنود الإسرائيليين حتى لو كان هذا هو
آخر شيء سأتمكن من
فعله [موسيقى] [
موسيقى] [موسيقى
]
[موسيقى]
أحيانًا عندما نروي قصصًا عن
وطننا، نحب القصة لأنها
تتعلق بوطننا  ونحن نحب
وطننا أكثر بسبب
القصة، فنحن نعرف أن إسرائيل ستقتلنا
على أي حال، فنحن نتضور جوعًا، ونحن
محاصرون، ونحن في
هذا المكان، ونعلم أن كل هؤلاء
ستقتلنا إسرائيل بأي طريقة
تريدها إسرائيل.  نحن راكعون وإسرائيل تختار
قتلنا عندما تريد قتلنا فلماذا
لا تقاوم وتموت في
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
كرامة
[موسيقى]